welcome to this video playing ken can
patch Edom okay maybe this is his real
name Kent axioms their name nope from
South Africa and koechlin I'm trying to
play aggressively against that not go to
the usual Catalan try to do to play em
aggressively with be five so this is a
form of benoni but we're like quickly
why his knowing he knows the theory ah
hmm how is this plate again a six don't
don't see that too often that people
actually know this line especially not
with this type of writing I hope yeah
maybe e5 get some gets ugly quickly okay
let's hope that it's not it's not so
terrible if ifs always critical here
like II five takes Knight takes and then
the long diagonal I need to do that it's
not much not much else i hope that i can
get rid of the the lights coming bishop
okay
I need to try to exchange that one this
position is not so terrible if I get the
Knights of the night on c4 this is some
my enemy number one yes good position
almost try to exchange it on e5 okay
this is a slight relief I thought Bishop
f4 was a bit a bit more testing but
maybe I'm wrong it's possible of course
okay if I if I'm able to exchange now oh
here and i am i'm talking so he must
this one okay here and all the way to be
5 p-5 deform this is ok i think this
should be okay now if he goes Bishop f4
supporting e5 I have rupee aid to block
this and then night b5 to deform this
this must be okay of course my majority
the two against one here c5 before
against boot to is a bit hampered by
this early before move which I couldn't
really avoid but the the square on de
force of course fantastic the question
is night deform now I can first play the
smooth it's good anyway 94 next here in
this this kind of situation where you
can put two pieces on defaults always a
question what piece to put on define
bishop device is also not silly maybe
trying to get the bishops often than the
night to reform which is also very very
good piece but it's not clear that
turn this is better I'll play I think
I've prefer Knight d4 and maybe Queen B
5 but can prepare prepare that I don't
need to do it immediately okay let's
let's jump now I wonder if you can play
with the tool trying to sacrifice an
exchange
hmm yeah this isn't in this kind of
position the Queen on this am now maybe
queen da to f 6m the the Queen maybe was
better on the age that's really a
possibility okay let's not hesitate too
long let's get ahead I'm attacking a 5
i'm attacking the Queen so and if he
needs to take the a pawn will be weak
and I have then three against one
majority but should be really nice yeah
I think after group f1 was a mistake
Queen B 5 looks quite strong now
yeah this should be should be good for
black or any yeah this is really good
for black this was one problem we
couldn't move the Queen away he was
disordered quite resigned yeah of course
it was a really huge rating mismatch but
it happens I was really a bit shocked
that he noted that he knew the theory
this is the way Kramnik is playing this
line and it's very dangerous John the
question is if we can play a quickie
five really this might be might be the
problem something like that intending
they're not that one intending d6 know
if this can be if can be very tricky to
get this like really as some black
really needs to play some some damn ugly
moves him to stay in the game yeah
that's not looking good probably this is
this is the the reputation of of my
moves a six I think that the critical
Linus is to take even on money form
right here here still d5 but I think now
after i get the bishops off here the
bishop on on on before i think the worst
is over adhere p.m. yeah this is a i
think the last spot where to look for
something maybe he ever should therefore
it's a bit that's a bit tougher because
now i cannot so easily play 95
conference to play g5 here quick cool
move then 95
jump maybe maybe that's not so bad and
the game it it's a typical scenario in
the Benoni of two sets of minor pieces i
exchanged and especially if one of those
minor pieces blacks LightSquared bishop
then the Benoni is excellent somehow
it's the case that for the structure
Black has too many pieces and if he
needs to if he is able to exchange one
or two pair of minor pieces it's very
helpful and he is of course this is
strong square on deform very strong 94
was already good okay thanks for
watching